um who do you think you are you know you  pompous ass uh calling Mega people  mentally ill you know that's a real  stretch you know you got to get off this  stuff  who Do You Think You Are  nobody  so again listen  uh I have never said  all Mega people are mentally ill  but I've interviewed enough of them and  our correspondents have interviewed  enough of them to know  that some of these Maga people are  mentally ill and the manifestation is an  obsession with Trump and Trump  paraphernalia and Trump gear others just  are ignorant about politics others are  selfish and greedy and they identified  that Trump policies would be good for  them you know it's a combination who am  I I'm just like you I you have an  opinion and I have an opinion and we  express the opinions it just might be  that more people are listening to my  opinion than yours